when you spend your life comparing
yourself to somebody else it's hard to
build your own personality
that's exactly what happened to yelena
bulova marvel's other black widow
here's what you need to know about this
spy and assassin
in one of the more lurid origin stories
in marvel history back when the company
was still publishing comics in its
adults-only max line
yelena bolova's backstory was revealed
in the series black widow pale little
spider
her trainer and mentor colonel
starkovsky is found killed in a russian
fetish club
starkovsky had been training her in
combat since she was a pre-teen
and elena thought of him as a father
figure however he found himself thinking
of her in a different way
and felt tremendous guilt about it he
turned to the bdsm
experts at club fabrica headed by a
mysterious woman named nikki
she groomed a yelena lookalike named
petra
using files starkovsky had stolen petra
would humiliate and degrade him while
fulfilling his fantasies
and this allowed starkovsky to stay sane
however
petra started to believe that she
deserved to be the black widow
and killed starkovsky in a rage yelena
went undercover and encountered nicki
who eventually helped
elena capture petra yelena killed petra
without hesitation and returned to
receive her next orders as the new black
widow
after she left it was revealed that
nicki was a spy and the whole mission
was designed to test elena's field
readiness
wow how would you do that elena bulova's
first appearance came in the marvel
knights in humans
series when general yuri stallienko was
leading an assault on atalan
the home of the inhumans the inhumans
had isolated themselves from the human
race for years for precisely this reason
they didn't want to engage with the wars
and politics of the human race
of course while atlan was ruled by the
wise black bolt his brother maximus the
mad was always stirring up trouble
maximus had secretly reached out to
stallienko giving him information
and technology that he knew would allow
the invaders to pierce adeland's
defenses and
ultimately allow him to rule in order to
make this work a lot of espionage had to
occur
stallienko sent his newly activated
black widow yelena to deliver what
appeared to be a gift to a u.s
ambassador
she told him that he needed to get it
into the hands of the inhumans and it
would act as a trojan
horse emitting a frequency that would
lower the negative space barrier that
protected atalan
the plan worked as the ambassador gave
the gift to an inhuman diplomat after
the u.s refused to intervene directly to
stop the attacks on adalan
in the end black bolt knew what maximus
had planned all along and went along
with it before he crushed stalingo's
forces and made it appear as though
adalan had been destroyed
during the 1999 black widow mini-series
colonel khan of the rapistanian army
commissioned a scientist named dr didier
anez to create a biological weapon
called the deathless frenzy
this biotoxin once it infected its
targets turned them
into invincible berserker warriors until
it cycled through their bodies and
ravaged them
naturally the u.s and russia didn't want
a rogue state in possession of such a
dangerous weapon more to the point both
countries wanted it for themselves
so both countries sent their black
widows to retrieve it natasha romanov
for the u.s
and elena bulova for russia and their
first encounter natasha's experience
overcame yelling as surprise factor and
sheer ruthlessness
yelena immediately told natasha that she
was the new black widow revealing her
obsession with her
natasha understood how to use that to
her advantage as she coolly manipulated
the younger spy
natasha kidnapped inez and forced him to
create a vaccine
then she drew elena out of hiding and
faked her own death
manipulating elena to go back to
rapistan natasha genuinely felt sorry
for elena and the life that was chosen
for her but that didn't mean that she
wasn't going to use her
natasha went undercover to vaccinate
khan's men and destroyed the virus while
yelena served as her distraction when
elena tried to kill her natasha said
that elaine's passion for the game
wouldn't let her do it just yet and she
was right
elena's next encounter with natasha in
the 2001 black widow miniseries was even
more one-sided and brutal
during their first encounter natasha
learned that the new head of the red
room was none other than general yuri
stalienko
a former mob level thug who managed to
worm his way into a position of power
natasha had shield abduct yelena from
her apartment and perform
face-off style facial cosmetic surgery
it's like
looking in a mirror only not a confused
elena woke up in natasha's new york
apartment with
natasha's face and a cheery daredevil
there to hit on her
natasha as elena picked a fight with her
in public baiting elena as natasha to
shoot her
a confused but angry elena obliged even
as natasha was really pretending to be
elena
taunting her that she was too old and
too slow
the whole point of this was for natasha
to get in with stallienko and learn his
plans he had a bunch of nukes stashed in
new york and though stalliengo suspected
she wasn't really
elena and sent an assassin after her she
was still a step ahead of him
meanwhile shield was pretending to chase
elena all around new york
exhausting the confused spy before
daredevil finally let her off the hook
natasha then made sure elena heard
stalienko admit that elena was
expendable and he'd use her without
hesitation
after the widows captured him elena
attacked natasha natasha revealed that
she was trying to save elena and teach
her that everyone gets used in espionage
when natasha met elena for the third
time things got weird
well weirder the red room was hunting
down former black widow agents but
natasha turned the tables and killed her
pursuers and their accomplice
the ceo of an american drug company that
made her a wanted fugitive so she found
her way to cuba where she knew
elena had defected this is where their
relationship thawed as a melo yelena had
been living it up after making millions
as a lingerie model and business owner
she had retired from the spy game and
was living in luxury
she also provided a place for girls to
get off the street and gave them
medicine
she was happy to offer safe harbor for
natasha in exchange for natasha roughing
up some drug suppliers who had jacked up
the prices on their supply
natasha did this but realized that these
dealers were working for
gynecon the company whose ceo she had
killed natasha was later kidnapped by a
couple of killers looking for revenge
but elena and daredevil rescued her
after she had been drugged
natasha stayed in cuba for a while
recovering and they became
friends the next time elena popped up in
new avengers number six she was back in
the spy game and had started working for
shield although she was part of a
renegade unit that was mining savage
land vibranium
unlike wakandan vibranium which absorbed
sound savageland vibranium destroyed the
integrity of anything metallic
the new avengers came across the
operation while they were hunting down
carl lycos a man who could transform
into a sentient pteranodon called
sauron an energy leech who specifically
homed in
on mutant energy bulova and her unit
also attacked the new avengers but
sauron burned her with fire before he
was finally defeated
bulova was whisked away by aim who saved
her life and offered her a deal
her body was now permanently scarred and
broken but if she agreed to have her
consciousness
transferred into the body of the new
super adaptoid her power would be
limitless and she could get back at the
new avengers the super adaptoid could
absorb the powers of anyone upon contact
and those powers would stack in new
avengers annual number one yelena
attacked avengers tower when she
absorbed the powers of the sentry it
appeared that there was no way the
avengers could stop her
iron man summoned his entire armory of
suits against her
wearing her down as they fought her
remotely that gave the sentry time to
activate his other evil self within him
the void and push it in elena sensing a
mission failure aim destroyed elena
remotely
yelena balova has often been involved in
many hidden corners and cracks of the
marvel universe
one of the stranger ones was her
membership in a secret team called
vanguard
an elite black ops squad that
specialized in assassinations across the
world
their leader was trenton kraft alias
colonel america
the product of a companion to the super
soldier program of world war ii
whereas captain america was developed as
a peak physical specimen kraft was
developed as the most powerful
telekinetic mind on the planet
however he was too powerful and couldn't
control his powers which led to a
disastrous first mission where he
destroyed an entire city
he spent the next 60 years secretly
honing his powers as he oversaw this
team
kraft was seemingly assassinated but it
turned out to be a complicated series of
double crosses
that culminated with craft showing up
alive and deciding to obliterate the
team
since they were compromised whether or
not this version of elena survived the
end of the story is
unclear elena disappeared from the
public eye until norman osborne found
her breaking into a shield facility
which led to an offer for her to lead
his team of thunderbolts during dark
rain
she proved to be a capable tactician and
leader of the group
however this wasn't actually elena at
all it was once again natasha romanov
assuming yelena's identity in order to
infiltrate the thunderbolts for nick
fury she secretly reported her
activities to fury who directed her on
her missions
of course this wasn't actually fury
osborne knew she wasn't bulova because
he had bulova in a stasis tube
recovering from her destruction as the
super adaptoid so he
intercepted natasha's communications and
pretended to be fury
hoping that natasha would eventually
lead him to his foe
he had the thunderbolts tracked down
songbird and then ended the charade
ordering the thunderbolts to kill them
natasha and songbird managed to escape
when
several of the thunderbolts turned on
each other
some time later andrew forsen the
scientist supreme of aim
recovered that stasis tube from osborne
and revived elena
aim had purchased the island of barbuda
and decided to declare themselves a
sovereign nation
barbuda became a haven for supervillains
and elena became its minister of state
the secret avengers stormed the facility
as things began to fall apart for aim
a captured mockingbird tried to escape
but was met by elena and they fought
at the end of the fight mockingbird was
shot and killed except it wasn't
mockingbird
she'd placed a hologram device on yelena
that made her look like mockingbird
elena was dead yet again if you're
wondering how elena found time to have
all these adventures when seemingly
every story involves her dying or
captured by shield there is a simple
answer
your clones your copies
of people out here in the world
what clones the red room spy program
that produced deadly female spies quite
literally produced deadly female spies
they kept clones of natasha and elena on
hand and had a psychic operative named
epsilon red
who maintained all of their memories and
could download them into new bodies
natasha romanov was killed by the hydra
version of captain america during secret
empire
however the red room activated a new
natasha clone when the clone became
aware of all this
she used a blank slate yelena clone as
fodder to impersonate shield agent
sally skidz blevins in order to fake
sally's death
she then took apart the red room and
destroyed all of the clones
natasha sent another yelena clone
disguised as her in order to throw off
hawkeye and the winter soldier
but not before she killed the real elena
then she killed the clones as well to
put an end to her friend and rival once
and for all
at least until the character likely gets
a well-earned reboot following the black
widow film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one